alexis bonjour
merci d'être avec nous ce matin en
direct sur rt france on le disait le
projet de loi instaurant le pass
vaccinale a donc été adopté en deuxième
lecture à l'assemblée nationale et ce
n'est pas une surprise un de la part de
la majorité gouvernementale alexis n'ont
hélas non on a vu le vice-président de
l'assemblée nationale d'ailleurs dire
mais le champagne aux frères ils sont
très contents les députés marcheurs
d'avoir pu passer ce pass vaccinale à
185 vote sait rien sur les 577 députés
que compte l'assemblée nationale débat
bâclé comme toujours et la volonté
toujours la même de l'exécutif de passer
en force avec une mesure totalement
anachronique c'est ça qui est incroyable
de les pays européens nos pays voisins
sont en train de passer à autre chose
avec la vague du variant au micron
toutes les mesures qui étaient des
mesures coercitives des mesures qui
limitent et des libertés sont en train
de tomber en espagne en grande bretagne
et ailleurs et la france qui nagent
totalement à contre-courant avec une
mesure qui ne sert absolument à rien
puisque le ministre de la santé
triplement vacciner avec astrazeneca
pfizer et modern art et bien ils
attrapent les comics donc tout le monde
vacciner ou non peut attraper ce variant
au micro et être contagieux donc
l'efficacité du pass pour la vaccination
là encore il s'agit de braquer une
frange de la population
cinq à six millions de personnes selon
emmanuel macron les non-vaccinés cela
n'iront pas se faire vacciner avec se
passe ils continueront d'être mis au ban
d'une société qui décidément sous
l'égide des malades macron a promu la
casse sociale la discrimination et la
politique du bouc émissaire donc encore
un vote lamentable encore un vote qui ne
sert à rien encore un vote d'une loi qui
me paraît totalement anachronique alors
que les données de ce virus ont
totalement changé et que certains pays
choisissent de vivre avec une épidémie
non pas une pandémie alors elle si les
débats vont se poursuivre aujourd'hui au
sénat à quoi s'attendre de la part des
sénateurs après l'échec des négociations
la commission mixte paritaire jeudi au
toujours quelques luttes picrocholines
quelques mots par ci quelques
changements à la marge sur une loi qui
ne mérite rien d'autre que la poubelle
et l'oubli c'est quand même terrible de
voir que pendant des semaines des jours
nos élus nous représente la nation ont
perdu du temps à parler d'une loi qui ne
sert à rien regardez il faudrait en
l'occurrence plutôt avoir des
commissions qui vont enquêter sur le
coût faramineux des tests qu'ovide
plusieurs milliards par mois sur le coût
faramineux de des fermetures de lits
également enfin on marche sur la tête la
façon dont on a dépensé sans compter
pour les tests dépensé sans compter pour
empêcher les français de vivre en
fermant l'économie la dette qui explose
c'est lahoud ou les sénateurs et députés
devraient être unis et travailler pour
faire le bilan catastrophique des
manuels macro et dire que c'est
proprement scandaleux et on ne peut pas
accepter ça et que font-ils ils
discutent d'une loi liberticide à contre
courant de tout inutile et dangereuse
c'est vraiment d'une déception sans nom
alors le sénat sans doute amènera encore
d'autres modifications mais sénateurs
comme députés auraient dû se lever comme
un seul homme ait refusé de discuter
cette loi qui ne sert à rien si ce n'est
en mer dès les français comme le disait
lui-même le chef de l'état alors les
oppositions elle dénonce une manoeuvre
politique de quoi crisper encore un peu
plus la campagne présidentielle
finalement ici mais c'est bien le pari
des manuels macron ces deux complètement
phagocyté cette campagne présidentielle
en se posant comme le sauveur des
français face au co vide avec au micro
c'est très simple les contaminations
vont baisser la vaccination ayant fait
son travail 77 % de français vaccinés
même si vous attrapez au micro et bien
les formes graves ont baissé vous
regardez aujourd'hui les hôpitaux sont
en danger comme chaque hiver avec les
épidémies de grippe et autres donc va
fermer le maquereau ils jouent la montre
il empêche les gens de faire campagne de
ses concurrents politiques de faire
campagne sur d'autres thèmes notamment
son bilan il est incroyable quand même
il passe son temps à faire des promesses
15 milliards à la police 8 milliards par
ci et c'est l'échec pour sauver les
entreprises alors qu ils les empêchent
de travailler et donc il est en train
d'empêcher tous ses autres concurrents
de faire campagne et dans son temps le
maître des horloges des biens il se
posera en mars sans doute en vainqueur
du coc vide et se présentera aux
candidats à ce moment là la dernière
minute pour dire voilà j'ai une gestion
formidable du comité c'est faux regardez
les enseignants étaient dans la rue
cette semaine il a fallu se battre pour
avoir des masques ffp2 deux ans après le
début de cette crise toujours pas de
purificateurs d'air on a vu je vous
parlais des du coût faramineux de
milliards d'euros pour les tests qui
sont ce qu'ils sont mais n'ont pas
forcément une fiabilité à 100% donc on
est vraiment là dans un refus de bilan
dans une course en avant et dans une
manipulation comme sait les faire
emmanuel macron tout en empêchant tout
le monde de faire campagne en imposant
ce thème du grenat virus du coc vide
alors que tous les autres pays passe à
autre chose et qu'il est temps de parler
économie emploi pouvoir d'achat merci
beaucoup alexis alexis poulain
éditorialiste sur rt france a retrouvé
sur les réseaux sociaux fois